les forces de l'ordre sont soudainement
plus visible autour de la colline du
parlement
vigilance accrue après des incidents
remarquer membres des médias et
parlementaires ont été la cible de
tentatives d'arrestation citoyenne y
compris le chef du npd qui s'inquiètent
du climat actuel 3 spécialiste des arts
martiaux john meeting assure qu'il
aurait pu se défendre mais ce n'est pas
le cas de tous ses collègues hongrois
s'assurer que les députés qui peut être
un peu plus âgées ou les femmes n'a
aucune menace dans leur vie plusieurs
élus ont exprimé des craintes pour leur
sécurité
au bureau du président de la chambre des
communes ces derniers jours des élus de
premier rang sans protection exposés au
risque c'est chose courante près du
parlement
les gardes du corps devrait si la
compagnie heli ministres et les chefs de
partis certains pensent que oui on
reçoit tous des menaces sur une base
quotidienne et on ne sait jamais lequel
des hurluberlus va passer à l'acte ceux
qui crient une les sécurités plus ou
moins prononcé cet ancien ministre
conservateur se rappelle d'une
altercation pendant le conflit de
travail chez air canada
bonjour à l'aéroport de montréal un
employé c'est à prochainement mais
madame bien mais n'est ce label il est
allé chercher un café dans un restaurant
et il m'a qui a fait qu'ils passaient
tout près de moi qui est allé frapper
d'armure donc y être moment là c'est les
opa saljic
à québec les ministres ont une garde
rapprochée pourquoi pas à ottawa
est-ce que les chauffards il faut
trouver l'équilibré entre sécurité et
accessibilité
moi j'étais aussi mnsd mer donc on veut
avoir quand même de la place pour
respirer on veut pas passer pour être en
quarts canet et puis se sentir nous
mêmes et rue j'ai des inquiétudes par
rapport à l'idée de créer des barrières
ouvre les gens ou que les gens ne
puissent pas connu les forces de l'ordre
sur la colline du parlement assure que
les mesures de sécurité sont ajustés
continuellement en fonction de la menace
mais des élus réclament une approche
plus musclée dès maintenant avant qu'un
incident plus graves ne l'obligent ici
louis blouin radio canada ottawa